so you open up in the book about like
speaking of being personal from the
beginning that's why i loved about
how raw and real you are because i feel
like sometimes that's few and far
between with people and the public guy
um but you you had to make an impossible
decision
during a pregnancy and um and i have
known people that have had the same
scenario so what happened
you know with this situation how did you
cope with it because it's a that's a big
thing to open up about
well what's interesting is that when i
for when we had to make a decision
because we found out once we got into
the second trimester by the way which
usually
you know once you get into that you're
like i'm in the clear yeah we found out
when we were
into our second trimester that there
were um some pretty devastating health
problems um and that the baby was at
risk i was at risk
the baby probably wouldn't survive and
that i was at risk for caring any longer
and we really weren't in a position to
the writing was on the wall there was
nothing we could do
um and it might my husband and i often
say that was
the worst day of our lives um
making that decision and
it's once i went through it i was really
mad at my body and myself like i thought
i did something to cause it which i
didn't
i didn't yeah you know but you just are
trying so hard to find an answer
and i found that once i went through
that i started finding out these other
women who've gone through similar losses
and nobody was talking about it yeah but
i felt that it was really important to
write about it
because i wanted other people to be able
to feel safe to share their story
and the fact that i wrote about it i
can't tell you how many people have
reached out
i can't imagine how much it's helped
them and now they're able to
vocalize what they went through or they
feel seen and heard and
it's something that was really hard for
me to share but i'm so glad i did
because
it it really helped again build this
community
and made it safe for for people to talk
about yeah and i i mean i'm
one who loves therapy so i just
sometimes like learning and they were
like just
saying it aloud helps you heal like just
saying it out loud and not keeping it
inside and it just kind of building up
like
saying it aloud helps the person saying
it just as much as somebody connecting
to the message and feeling the same way
so it's
very brave and it's very cool and you're
very strong woman
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going